now we were talking earlier with the
health secretary about coronavirus and
joining us now to give his take is the
chair at the British Medical Association
dr. John dat nag Paul thank you so much
for being with us it feels to me as if
people are trying to work out how
concerned they should be about
coronavirus how worried should we be
well clearly this is an issue of both
national and international concern so we
do need to be concerned we need to be
vigilant but equally proportionate in
our concern and not panic
or be alarmist we've seen some of the
government's ideas for a battle plan if
you like against coronavirus we spoke to
the health secretary Matt Hancock
earlier on the program he seemed to be
saying look the best thing you can do at
the minute is wash your hands knees into
your elbow etc and is that enough or
should we actually be looking at more
precautions such as the ones that other
countries are taking banning flights for
example from people who recently coming
from China banning meetings of over
5,000 people indoors are we doing enough
so each nation has to take its own
measures based upon circumstances in the
UK we've tested over 10,000 patients or
individuals and we have 23 confirmed
cases so at the moment and of course
this changes on an hour to hour day by
day basis at the moment the containment
seems to be the correct procedure and
therefore simple public health measures
like washing your hands for 20 seconds
making sure that you cover your nose in
a tissue if you sneeze or cough our
proven ways of containing spread of the
virus is another thing else that people
should be doing to keep themselves safe
I mean I was struck by the Dutch the
World Health Organization saying if
you're on over 60 perhaps think about
avoiding crowded places or places where
you could meet people who are sick I
mean it's that kind of self-preservation
if you like that some people should be
thinking about well we know that the
virus is relatively mild in healthy
adults and is much more potent and
causes more illness in those who are
older those with pre-existing medical
conditions and that's advice we give in
fact during the winter season anyway
we're not at that point at the moment
but of course again that advice which is
based around public health experts may
change on a day to day basis but we're
not at that point at the moment how
about traveling I mean if you were
someone over 60 would you be thinking
about going to Italy for example again
we have to be proportionate we have very
up-to-date advice on foreign travel so
anyone considering traveling abroad
should take that advice so again it's
about being proportioned and also making
sure that you seek the right advice it
feels as if caution or in proportion not
panicking it is the message coming
across from oneself and also from the
government given how quickly the virus
seems to have gripped certain countries
after entering them is there not I'm
worried that this is a little bit too
slow that we should actually be doing
things more quickly before we get to
that stage so absolutely whilst we are
at the moment focusing on containment at
this very moment I'm and for the last
few days of not weeks I would be hoping
and I believe there are plans that
should be made regarding an outbreak
that becomes more prevalent well
obviously we need to have emergency
planning for right up to worst-case
scenarios that has to be planned for now
in case that needs to be invoked that's
not been alarmist that's just being
sensible and that is what I believe the
government should be doing and are doing
what is that then well if we were to
have an epidemic in this country they
would need to be we need to move beyond
the containment phase to actually
mitigating or managing that crisis that
may involve for example having to reduce
or cancel planned emergency planned care
in hospitals for non-emergency
operations so that you prioritize the
availability of care for critically ill
patients so that's a sort of thing that
may need to happen but I don't want to
create alarm at this stage that those
discussions that planning will need to
be taking place now and I believe has
been doing so I'm interested
your thoughts and how prepared the
Health Service is for this kind of event
and a couple weeks ago you said this
about the NHS not of course in relation
to coronavirus stories of patient deaths
on corridors round emergency departments
and cancellations of patients procedures
as a daily occurrence are becoming the
new norm I mean could I out service cope
if coronavirus does become more serious
so I think this is the the difficulty
whilst we are rightly preparing for an
outbreak of coronavirus and trying to
contain the virus before this current
episode we had a Health Service in
December that was suffering record waits
for patients in casualty in emergency
departments record numbers of patients
on waiting lists and we heard from the
Royal College of Nursing that 75% of
nurses are now providing corridor care
so we have a Health Service already
under severe pressure and strain are
there enough beds frankly well I think
what would need to happen is that the
nature of the beds would need to change
you probably have to convert parts of
hospitals and wards from routine
services to emergency services or
critical care services these things
would have to be cancelled look if there
was going to be an outbreak or an
epidemic in this country on the
background of a Health Service that was
struggling to cope as the beam the BMA
have said as I've warned as we have the
patients in the in the nation experience
clearly they are going to be
consequences but and the right decisions
will need to be made and in an outbreak
in an epidemic those who are seriously
ill will need to be prioritized and
those plans would be I believe be
happening now because we do need to plan
for the future I mean John McDonald was
saying earlier that austerity on the NHS
could potentially hit how the
government's can respond to this kind of
thing is that right Matt Hancock said it
was not right we've been saying for a
long time
and not just us but all health experts
that we haven't an NHS that has the
sufficient numbers of beds
and staff compared to many other
European countries and we know for
example with when you look at critical
care beds Germany has four times as many
as we have so we clearly have a
background of not the sort of capacity
that the health service needs but having
said that in an emergency situation we
would have to adapt and make provision
for that emergency that faces us just
finally there's been lots of talk about
a vaccine how far away are we I'm
getting a corona virus vaccine so at the
moment a vaccine is being researched the
trouble is that it will take months for
that vaccine to actually be available
and that would be not in time for the
current situation we face so the the the
efforts that we're making now around
identification isolation containment it
is absolutely right and there are other
very practical issues that that we need
to take forward making sure that no one
who may be suspected of how carrying the
infection goes into a GP surgery you
know we've had cases where a patient may
have attended for example to get a fit
note for work and the practice has had
to close down for the day and those
sorts of issues can make a big
difference so it's really important that
the public understand the need to
isolate the need to seek advice from NHS
one-one-one we may need to move to more
remote working for example many GP
surgeries may be offering more telephone
appointments follow-up for patients on
the phone we may need to move to more
social distancing for more patients and
more workers working from home to try
and contain spread of the virus okay
thank you so much for coming on the
program I'd explained they liked it as
much appreciated thank you